Russia's President Vladimir Putin says
that Ukraine's counter-offensive is not
seeing any success saying that Kiev has
not been able to get through Russian
defenses Ukraine's counter-offensive in
the east and south of the country has
now entered its second month
I see all attempts by the enemy to break
through our defenses and this is their
objective which includes the use of
strategic reserves they have not been
successful for the entire time of the
offensive the enemy has no success
our correspondent AG joins us now from
the town of constantinifka which is
around 20 kilometers from bakmut as it
talk us through the latest there on the
fighting any movement as this
counter-offensive continues
well it's important to say there are
things that we are told by the Ukrainian
authorities and those things that we are
not told but saying that we have heard
from the deputy defense minister Hannah
Malia now what she has said is that the
Russians are actively advancing in the
copyansk direction for the last two days
now just north of here and she says that
the ukrainians are on the defensive
there she says that the battles are
Fierce and positions change several
times daily now that's quite sobering
that's quite honest from the Ukrainian
Deputy defense minister there because
because what we normally hear is about
the Ukrainian advances and now what we
are hearing uh from the ukrainians is
that the Russians are pushing back she
says in Bahamut they are on the southern
flank they are moving forward and they
have daily advances but again some of
those advances are very very minimal and
she said in other parts of Bahamut they
fire on the enemy and the enemy fires
back and she says that in adivka further
east to where I'm saying standing right
now they are Fierce back tells a no
change in positions now what I can tell
you is that last night was very busy
where we were in the east of Ukraine we
could hear aerate Sirens all night we
could hear firing going on in fact where
we were staying the walls were shaking
because of those strikes now what we
don't hear is what exactly has been
struck if a military Target is struck we
don't hear that from the ukrainians if a
civilian Target is hit we hear about a
residential building being hit and
people being injured but at the moment
there's no change in those front lines
but we are hearing from the ukrainians
now that in some places the Russians are
making some advances well we've also
meanwhile heard President Putin threaten
to retaliate with cluster Munitions if
the ukrainians use them but we know that
caves existing weapons and equipment
stocks aren't in the best shape are they
no they're not but in reality both sides
have already been using cluster
Munitions and that's been documented by
human rights organizations so when
President Vladimir Putin talks about
retaliating well the ukrainians will be
saying well you've already used so many
weapons already not just in the east of
Ukraine and the South but across the
country there's daily airstrikes and
drone strikes now what we did was we met
up with a tank unit in the east of the
country and there's two things that are
striking one is when you speak to the
soldiers they're morale but also how
very young they are some of these men
are only 21 years old and already been
fighting for a year but also the part of
eastern Ukraine that they're operating
in to the north east and south of them
are Russian troops there's a small
pocket in the east of Ukraine where
they're fighting and that's very very
difficult for for them but we met up
with this tank unit
under the cover of the forest these men
work on t-72 tanks some of which are
older than their parents
the location is secret it's close to the
front line because these tanks need to
be repaired and returned to the
battlefield quickly the methods are
simple and low-tech 21 year old bumper
as he is known as a mechanic and tank
driver he's just come back from Battle
it was like raining shells and mines on
us the field was full of craters and
mines and the commander of my unit died
when his tank burned with him in it the
work is arduous and difficult but
there's no other choice when they fixed
and upgraded the tanks make their way
back to their positions we have been
taken to where the tank is hidden now it
has to be really well hidden because
there's always drones up in the air
where Russians could spot the position
of the tank and then Target it this tank
crew are getting ready in case they
called out to fight
everything is simpler than this tank
than others
of course it's better to receive the
more modern Western tanks we could then
keep these in reserve it turns out we're
fighting t-72s against t-72s the Western
tanks are made to fight against
tank crews are in high demand and
essential to Ukraine's counter-offensive
500 days or four have passed and I
haven't seen my family I'm not giving
any leave there's no opportunity the two
sides are evenly matched and we barely
managed to beat them when the Call Comes
in they have to be prepared to take
positions
this part of eastern Ukraine has Russian
forces on three sides when firing they
have to be quick
a shell lands just meters away they've
been spotted they managed to get away
undercover it's always a relief but they
know every Mission could be their last I
said Al Jazeera near the front line
eastern Ukraine